Not only do I get invited
to THE Clambake Club
but I get to ride in
Celery Savoy's bathing machine.
Just when I thought I couldn't
have another greatest day
of my life, here I am.
Celery, is there anything
I need to know
for the initiation ceremony?
No, you do a bathing rite
in the ocean
and then we all stuff ourselves
with clams.
Yum, and then we sing
The Legend of The Clam,
which is our society's
official theme song.
Oh, I know it already.
♪ From the depths of the sand ♪
♪ To the silt of the sea ♪
♪ High tide, low tide ♪
♪ Barnacles and cla-- ♪
Save your voice, Lillian.
We all sing it together.
Also,
it's in C-sharp minor.
[gasps]
We're here.
Lillian,
why don't you go first?
[screams]
Oh, my dear.
I'm afraid all the spaces
on this side of
the beach
have been taken.
This beach
is for members only.
- Go that way.
- That's right.
You're on Rejects Beach,
Lillian.
Where you belong.
[distorted]
Poor people!
Hot dog?
Hot dog!
[rock music]
♪ ♪
[distorted laughter]
[crying]
(woman)
♪ Alone ♪
No!
(woman)
♪ I'm all alone ♪
♪ Alone ♪
♪ All by myself ♪
♪ I'm alone ♪